vi spiego il gioco in breve c'è una
mappa grande siamo in 100 giocatori
l'obiettivo è sopravvivere a tutti gli
altri rimanere ultimi che ho detto tutte
queste cose mangiando mina kinder brioss
e non è un placement che belle tette che
hai di sentire la tua voce
salve sono nuove realtà c'è qualcosa che
sono volumi amico che non mi ha ancora
presentato sul mio canale la prima volta
che c entri dato sul canale si chiama
thomas ciao thomas ciao ragazze la
fidanzata psicopatica quando il tuo
ragazzo non risponde ai messaggi aver
cos'è sta roba perché c'è un autobus che
con la sua moglie che gli sghei andavo
così a scuola vogliamo atterrare araki
agr e anarchia cresta bene breve 21 si
va a scuola che si apre paracadute da
solo da presa si aspetti dopo un tot sia
predatorio e dai per un attimo avuto il
timore che non si aprisse mi sono pagato
in ricetta dissi ma c'ero anch'io
la notizia vicino facendo sentire la
stessa aiuto ama puoi staccare messo
titolo che cosa ti dai no no no non
chiusa non farsi staccare il tempo di
entrare ha detto sì anche anche
assolutamente
eccovi un giorno dio mio dio euro
minchia ci avevo creduto non ho armi e
arrivo col ci sono più di tutto della
piccola ti faccia ha detto questo è per
sto per morire però ucciso ha ucciso a
picconate inizio o occhio cornice che
l'ho trovato
posso costruire un muro e manuale di
istruzione è stata un'ottima idea quella
di costruire un muro da funzionato di
brutto
nel pomodoro gigante vista italia italia
lamenteranno lega pro
no mi hanno tirato giù ho spaccato un
pezzo di pomodoro dio sono porto
perfetto tira giù stessa piccola forse
sarà funzionando costruzione funziona ha
funzionato
oddio come si usa un cieco un cecchino
davvero la pena si no eccolo
ti piace la mia mira thomas ma grazie
penserete di porcino di pietro la mia
assoluta visto uscire la finestra ma va
a bailar e si spara ci spara ci sta
dietro tale che le bende perfetto ne ho
io alcune tu mi sto curando o occhio
attento a non andare giù o una granata
eccoli insieme un angolino sì li ho
visti
non è uscito subito l'altro non sta
arrivando un altro allo scudo l'altro
una loro porca vacca medicina
devo curarmi si sta curando lì dietro
madonna quante armi aveva to the peak e
mamma mia
thomas 7 del rumore il corso pratico
sopra sopra sopra il suo premio scudetto
attenta che li lo vedi solo tempo cazzo
pagine giu
via via via via via vicino sfondare il
tetto sparano sì è vero era purissima
idea peccato ha tutte le armi
speriamo a fregarmi plasmato fuoco
uccisero chiaro che deve render meno
guarda cosa aveva fatto
il fucile guarda 5 stelle questo l'ho
rubato
ti vedo uno lontanissimo devo provarlo
no si stanno chiudendo a da nord est di
vedi a nord est che stanno creando un
accampamento micro lenti con la in testa
possiamo costruire adesso al momento
buono questa è le istruzioni dell'ikea
costruiamo con come lo faccia fallire
edile o mio discografica fortezza
credito e siamo in campagna sotto lei
alieni che rimini che ci mettevi xvi per
i cinque ci piaceva qua sotto dai
tecnici vedi parata ci chiedono cristina
siano rimasti in 10 dai eccolo dietro
litri noi kokkos 24 e vado dietro chiami
un po mannaggia quest'anno ci sentiva
una grande aula annuncia granate
l'ora che nasce questo qua no occhio
però anche tre va bene va bene quando è
rimasta chiara da solo porca vacca ne
risente la granata ma porca vacca sulla
cig issimi se non ti vedo arrivo c'è in
un altro le porte sfondo tutto luce un
bomber toto un'arma letto cucina santo
arriva arriva
dico ok c'è una trama cioè nella pistola
si vedrà
ma c'è una cosa che mi ha detto adesso
ci si fermi grande grande ressa vs
saliamo l'articolo
ho toccato arrivo uccisa
ho preso un bel po di roba vieni san
donato che arriverà sicuramente l'altro
ma perché sempre meno
beh ragazzi tiro ciao a tutti è stato un
bacio a giocare con l'impegno di piglio
sono il nostro assente di lui grazie
oggi c'è gente quasi ancora lucido 10
dentro l'altro fino a 235 c'è gente lì
dentro si sia assolutamente copriamo
centro la capra
così è molto sentita molto subito ma il
ragazzo lo raccontava erano medici e mi
presento la precedente sotto sotto il
ponte incidente sotto il po non sotto
sotto sotto il prodotto nostra del ponte
sul ponte sotto la strada
ok le visite di serie a ci fa proprio
forse scappare un action saremo andati a
titolare
distruggiamo il muretto chiamo che ansia
mamma mia se fa il giro nella 65 però
non la farà mai
sono andato ci stanno mi chiamano
entrato in faccia bravo è morto subito
cura di quello subito no dove cecchino
stylist hai viste riso non c'è chi era
quello che rimirava alticcia scatta
allora muro magari in un altro materiale
siamo talmente un tenero 45 secondi
quando non mi sparano fortissimi dentro
st collina non ha idea mi esce tirare su
un muro così kirby cura di lei 10 alive
top ten top ten thomas top ten
puntiamo a vincere ragazzi andiamo a
vincerlo del sito a destra questa è una
roccia
ok musik itcg cena ci sei
la donna
sono andato tutto il muro tutto il muro
visto sfondando tutto tutto hanno
sfondato anche la mamma
e nord e cliccate clockato il celato c'è
l'altro spara dall'altro
ogni tanto vado nyala incredibile
decimazione andiamo video con
incredibile incredibile di temù ricordi
ecco davanti a noi si stanno ammazzando
ho preso una volta
o che un ordinato giu
la doccia sicuro circolari siamo ultimi
contro un team è praticamente non ho
munizioni problemi reali stesso
intelligente lì sempre dietro se non
ammonizione di metri fucile da cecchino
né del sindacato riuscire a prenderlo
stessi si scopre è morto quattro altari
una live è morto bugelli dietro l'albero
sono da sopra si vede 85 sono sempre la
montagna stanno uscendo ci avviciniamo
ora vai vai adesso se c'è un momento
buono e questo diamo andiamo andiamo
devo prendere delle munizioni ragazzi
anche loro sono soprano i simpson tokyo
attaccati alla montagna attaccati e la
montagna stanno costruendo questo avrà
questo disco nali sopra finale il gran
finale
ayas loren arrivare di chi dove sono io
che sono io c'è la casa c'era casa
eccole sito no
una bravata
l'altro
bravissimo vittoria reale tra l'altro
fantastico raga bellissimo grandi quale
ragazzi dire che possiamo comprare
questo video su forte knight è stato
fighissimo ringrazio thomas mi ha
affiancato in questa vittoria
schiacciante senso civile preciso
momento mi piace anche nel sociale come
da tradizione
lascio anche il link del canale i
suicidi thomas che lui twitch a forte
questo incidente non ci vediamo al
prossimo vita da ragazzo
[Musica]